I grew up there before like dirt [__]
before like nothing when I was 16 I
moved out on my own my dad was a steel
work my mom was a drug addict but every
day I woke up and I said I'm not gonna
be like that right but now today I have
a hundred million dollar appraisal
company it's awesome but every single
day I wake up I still feel like that
little [__] poor that's good I hate
it but I'm happy with my wife I'm happy
with really kids we have a great family
here's what I believe I believe there's
three to four things that are deeply
inside of you that you've never said at
all now the second they come out of your
[__] mouth whether on an Instagram
video to the world because you're like
[__] it I'm gonna tear this whole thing
down or by going and sitting with
somebody in a private room or going to a
[__] Forest by yourself and screaming
it at the top of your lungs I don't care
how you do it I promise you without
knowing all the details there's poison
in you that you've never said out loud
I'm sure I'm sure I'm just saying this
was hard I could see it this is why I
always tell people to put out all their
[__] skeletons because that's the
[__] jail there's no amount of money
and success you're gonna make that's
gonna fix that you got to get the poison
out
thank you